oh my god you're gorgeous hello
everybody my name is markiplier happy
Monday and just a quick announcement for
the December of giving that I'm kind of
doing if you don't remember the best
fiends tournament is going on with
$50,000 going to charity and also I'm
going to be personally donating ten
thousand dollars to the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital but there's another
aspect of that and a few more down the
road before December ends so if you know
about red giant I've talked about them
before they're the people that my
brother works with and they've gotten
him and me to come out to San Diego
comic-con with an exhibitor badge even
when I had almost no subscribers when I
was very small and just starting out
they took me in they were really kind to
me and every year since then they've
done the same thing they've treated me
with respect they've given me all these
really cool privileges and
behind-the-scenes action to comic-con
San Diego which is the biggest comic-con
in the world if I'm not mistaken so
otherwise they've been really good to me
so thanks to them and working on them
with this December of giving that I've
been doing I will be able to donate
another ten thousand dollars this time
to the make-a-wish Foundation if you
don't know about the make-a-wish
Foundation they helped grant the wishes
of terminally ill or permanently
disabled children it's a really great
cause and one that you can actually see
a tangible benefit from the joy on their
faces is such a good reward unto itself
so I'm happy to be able to do this and
already I wanted in return was for me to
mention to you guys that they just
released their first full-length feature
film it's totally free it's available on
Hulu there's a link down the description
below it's called Niko the journey to
Magica now it is free but it is also a
kids movie it's getting good reviews so
far I have not watched the full thing
myself but if you're a parent of
children or if you're a kid yourself or
if you're a kid at heart maybe give it a
look if you enjoy it give it a rating
share it around if you feel like it but
all in all I'm just glad that we can do
this for a good cause and raise money
for the make-a-wish Foundation and all
the other charities that I planned in
the future it's going to be an awesome
December just like it's been an awesome
year and it's going to be an awesome
year next
here as well thank you all so much for
watching wait I'm not done I should also
mention that tomorrow there's a little
thing called player select by star bomb
the second star bomb album is coming out
tomorrow that I think you all should
definitely check out just trust me you
might want to give this one a look
because I heard there's some pretty
talented people on the album maybe in
one song in particular in other news I'm
happy the five nights at Freddy's 2 is
finally over people keep telling me that
five nights at Freddy's 3 is coming
along people keep telling me to play
five nights at Treasure Island which is
like a Disney version of five nights at
Freddy's don't know if I'm gonna play
that it looked rather silly but hey I
might give it a try
I've got a lot of other stuff planned
but also I'm going to be very busy for
the holidays I'm leaving back to his
family again this weekend
and I'm gonna be gone pretty much all of
Christmas but I'll be able to record so
I'll pre record I'll record in advance
I'll do everything it takes to make sure
the videos keep coming because you guys
have been amazing we're closing in on 5
million subscribers and also I have a
haircut planned tomorrow I will get my
hair cut I promise all of this
sadly the floof is gonna go away I'm
sorry
but I'll look good either way that was
gorgeous just like you GE so thanks
again everybody for watching and your
undying support and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
you